[Applause]
Herculean efforts are the everyday task
of dedicated storytellers and no one
knows that better than production
designers who craft the worlds that
transport delight challenge and inspire
us is to the brilliantly talented men
and women who create the rounds that
give life to worthwhile stories here are
the nominations for achievement in
production design American hustle
production design by Judy Becker and set
decoration by Ethel Ethel gravity
production design by Andy Nicholson and
set decoration by Rosie Goodwin and
Joanne will the great gatsby production
designed by Katherine Martin and set
decoration by Beverly down her
production design by KK Barrett and set
decoration by Gene sedin twelve years a
slave
production designed by Adam Stockhausen
and set decoration by Alice Baker and
the Oscar goes to the great gatsby
Katherine Martin production
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you thank you to the Academy thank
you to our fellow nominees we were among
a great group of people I accept this
award on behalf of the truly many
technicians who fall under the umbrella
of the art department and believe you me
I'm Gatsby there were many many very
talented technicians who worked on the
film I'd like to thank Karen Murphy my
associate production designer neither
Bev or I would be standing here if it
wasn't for you our supervising art
director our supervising art director
and Gracie you rock and you swear a lot
thank you and I've just got to shout out
to my children or they'll never forgive
me hi Lilly hi William thank you
[Applause]